et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe froguel généticien chercheur
professeur à l'impérial collège de
londres et à l'université lille 2
bonsoir fini progamme merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés jean lain à cappelle
député européen est reine
bonsoir à vous aussi alors l'agent sein
on vient de le dire du médicament
européen qui a commencé aujourd'hui
l'examen du vexin rue spoutnik vais
étape cruciale a on le disait en vue de
son développement dans l'union
européenne qui en a bien besoin
on rappelle que le vaccin russa a été
déjà utilisée en russie dès l'été
dernier l'étude du land 7 qui confirme
de bons résultats elle elle date de plus
d'un mois un peu plus d'un mois et 2
jours précisément pourquoi seulement
aujourd'hui jean lain à cappelle vos
piètres dans le coeur du réacteur
puisque vous êtes député européen mais
écoutez j'avais moi même formule 1 en
tant que député européen
une question il ya plusieurs semaines en
demandant pourquoi nous ne faisons la
france les nations aux européennes et
l'union européenne pourquoi après ceux
tel retard ne n'était pas le pr
n'étaient pas des dispositions pour
justement pouvoir commander combler des
failles et commandé notamment le vaccin
russe auquel faisait allusion et je n'ai
d'ailleurs jamais eu de réponses à ces
questions que j'ai formulée mais il est
temps en effet que l'union européenne
serait parce que nous avons eu lieu le
fiasco des masques en début d'année le
fiasco des tests en cours d'année et
puis nous avons maintenant comme le
fiasco des vaccins puisque je vais
parler de la france mais nous sommes
trente septième ce matin d'après les
chiffres trente septième rang mondial du
nombre de personnes vaccinées
donc c'est bien avant absolument nos
très faible tout à fait incohérent
inacceptable pour la septième puissance
mondiale et l'ensemble de l'union
européenne est extrêmement faible
l'ensemble de l'union européenne
donc nous avons des pays comme la grande
bretagne qui ont vacciné
j'ai les chiffres devant moi plus de 20
millions de personnes quand la france a
vacciné 1 million 700 mille personnes
sur les deux doses donc on est très en
retard et ce scandale est pas normal il
ya une double faute où il ya je dirais
un double problème il ya l'union
européenne qui a très mal négocié qui
s'est entouré de personnes qui ne
savaient pas négocié qui a voulu prendre
comme clef d'entrée
prix mais je crois quand on est en
guerre c'est pas le prix qu'il faut
prendre en prennent ces les quantités
c'est la rapidité
il faut qu'on soit les meilleurs et ils
n'ont pas su le faire
ils ont été ils ont manqué de
transparence dans les négociations ils
n'ont pas impliquer les nations dans les
négociations et puis très sincèrement
ils n'ont pas su négocier s'entourer
d'experts j'entendais le président
d'astra l'un des vaccins l'autre jour
qu'il disait eh bien écoutez moi j'ai vu
les contrats il n'y a pas de contrat aux
seins nus européenne c'était des
intentions d'achat en revanche il le
comparer aux contrats des britanniques
il disait le montant la bernique c'est
au moins claires et des conditions des
raisons il valait quantité fixe et
d'aider des livraisons est l'un des
pelles et et de retard vous savez quand
on est quand on est en guerre quand on
veut être bon quand on est efficace et
comment défendre son peuple et ses
peuples ce qu'est l'union européenne
bien leur est dû s'entourer des
meilleurs elle n'a pas su le faire
j'espère que l collège val retard et
bien sûr le vaccin russe est une
opportunité pour le faire mais que de
temps que le temps que le temps pour
enfin le faire la hongrie la slovaquie
ont décidé de le faire l'allemagne
d'ailleurs sans le dire a décidé elle
aussi de commander auprès d'autres
laboratoires des vaccins pour combler
cette défaillance européenne la france
est toujours en retard hainard dans la
dernière on va voir justement certains
pays qui sont affranchis un certain
d'ailleurs ont déjà reçu le spoutnik
vais regarder cette carte en distingue
entre ceux qui ont déjà passé commande
en slovaquie hongrie et république
tchèque la slovaquie qui a été
d'ailleurs fourni cette semaine on
pourparlers l'autriche vous l'avez dit
jean marie cappel et puis qui est
d'accord pour en commander quand tu
auras les autorisations l'allemagne
s'est déjà déclaré philippe froguel
clairement on devrait s'affranchir selon
vous des règles de l'union européenne
pour aller plus vite au nom de la santé
publique surtout poussé l'union
européenne à être plus actives aller
plus vite bien entendu mais pas qu'ils
allaient plus vite a aussi débloqué des
sous pour des programmes aura dépassé
les vaccins actuels parce que il ya des
risques aujourd'hui que ces vaccins ne
soit pas efficace j'ai bien noté que le
danemark et l'autriche
c'est une alliance avec israël pour
faire là pour faire ce genre de choses
c'est au niveau européen
si l'europe de la santé existant qu'il
faudrait il faudrait faire tout cela
aujourd'hui le choix est très compliqué
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de retard
je pense que la responsabilité n'est pas
que dans la l'europe en tant que tel il
ya eu la présidence allemande et à
l'année dernière il ya eu un jeu avec la
france avec l'italie qui ont voulu se
passer de la com et européenne pour
négocier directement avec les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
ils l'ont fait à leur manière en ne
croyant pas trop aux vaccins et rennes
je pense que c'est comme d'habitude
c'est toujours beaucoup trop facile de
s'en prendre à bruxelles alors qu'il ya
une responsabilité des états je répète
de la présidence allemande de la france
et d'autres qui ont voulu jouer à la
fois leur jeu à dicter ensuite alors des
règles qui étaient mauvaises
à la commission européenne et la
commission européenne
on sait qu'elle est très bureaucratique
on sait qu'elle est très lente et
qu'elle n'est pas fait pour les grandes
crises et c'est bien c'est un des vrais
problèmes et il faudrait que la
commission européenne et permettre
d'agir vite en cas de pandémie ce qui
pour l'instant n'existe pas mais quand
même rappeler que l'europe de la santé
il n'existe pas c'est pas avoir établi
une prérogative européenne c'est
peut-être quelque chose qu'il faudra
qu'il faudra changer donc pour répondre
à votre question je ne sais pas s'il
faut commander en dehors de l'europe je
sais même pas derrière ce qui est permis
ou pas permis la seule chose que moi je
dis à en tant que médecin c'est qu'il
faut tout faire pour qu'on ait assez de
vaccins pour tous c'est qu'en france il
y en a pas assez
et quelles que soient les
responsabilités d'ailleurs même temps tu
en as assez on n'arrive pas à les
distribuer à quand même près de 75% des
doses de vaccin astrazeneca qui n'ont
pas été distribuées et c'est peut-être
ça le principal problème en france
et pour revenir à soutenir si le vaccin
est que sans marcher aussi bien qu'il en
a l'air je ne vois pas pourquoi on se
des bassins puisque de toute façon en
france je ne vois pas exactement comment
le président de la république pourra
tenir ses promesses puisque à la seconde
on n'a pas de possibilité de vacciner un
million de personnes
avant avant l'été donc il faudra bien
faire venir des vaccins d'ailleurs je
voudrais vous faire écouter un conte
qu'elle celui du docteur laurent
alexandre qui trouve qu'en matière de
vaccination justement les 27 n'ont pas
été bon mais alors pas bon du tout
écouter l'europe s'est ridiculisée
l'angleterre a bien mieux réussi que
l'union européenne est aujourd'hui de
ralentir de prendre un mois de retard
sur l'enregistrement du vaccin johnson
and johnson qui al avantage de n'avoir
qu'une prise c'est grotesque
c'est dramatique donc l'union européenne
c'est une faillite complète sur ce
programme vaccinal
le royaume-uni donc il réussit mieux que
nous selon laurent alexandre 600 mille
doses par jour on répète ce chiffre
c'est un petit peu la revanche j'en
alain capelle des états souverains fini
pour elle nous le disait ça serait bien
que les états puissent aussi décider
seul sans sa franchissent enfin c'est
pas exactement vos mots mais en tout cas
voilà en donnant peut-être moins de
pouvoirs à la commission européenne qui
sont responsables de leurs propres
décisions mais enfin voilà le royaume
uni prouve que lui peut prendre d'essai
ses décisions de manière souple c'est
cette revanche de l'état nation aux gens
là la capelle mais vous l'avez
parfaitement dit et d'ailleurs l'exemple
de la grande bretagne et est
symptomatique c'est l'illustration
exactement de ce que happy souverain est
capable de faire plus que la grande
bretagne n'aurait jamais vaccine autant
de personnes si elles étaient encore
intégré bien sûr à l'union européenne
elle a vacciné aujourd'hui 30% de la
population avec une première dose 30% de
la population
plus de 20 millions de personnes quand
nous sommes nous les français à 4,5 pour
cent autant vous dire que il ya même pas
de comparaison possible
il ya même pas d'excusé possible nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans un piège qu'est
l'union européenne qui vous lisiez
professeur qui en effet normalement n'a
pas dans ses prérogatives
la santé mais pourtant pourtant après le
fiasco des masques après l'abandon de
l'italie notamment un qui criait sos au
bas de mars sur dix ans on n'a pas de
matelas de protection
aidez nous et personne ne la soutenait
l'europe avait promis de devenir une
grande robe de la santé et il en est
fait un point d'honneur à démontrer
justement que l'union européenne pouvait
nous protéger en fin dé protéger les
peuples européens
eh bien elle s'est encore trompée elle a
encore failli et on n'y arrivera pas en
effet tant qu'on est constitué de cette
manière là avec une europe fédérale où
tout est contrôlé par bruxelles et où
les peuples donc peuvent pas avoir une
souveraineté la souveraineté est
indispensable sur les missions
importantes
et quand on déclare que nous sommes en
guerre il faut bien sûr redonner des
pouvoirs aux français l'union européenne
a interdit aux nations européennes de
négocier parallèlement auprès de
laboratoires avec lesquels elle négocier
donc d'une part elle les a pas intégrées
elles à m'intégrer dans la négociation
d'autre part alors interdit négocier
alors je dis dans son utilisation qui
complètement dingue vous savez c'est la
même situation
permettez moi ce parallèle la même
situation que sur la fermeture des
frontières
le 24 janvier dernier nous demandions
par la voie du rassemblement national le
président de marine le pen la régulation
des frontières tout le monde ou ryanair
dix ans le virus n'a pas de passeport
vous êtes ridicule il est irresponsable
et vous êtes extrémistes et bien côté là
fallu un an un an pour que l'union
européenne comprenne que réguler les
frontières ça permet quand même de
stopper et de freiner le virus et
l'allemagne d'ailleurs viennent fermer
ses frontières de la france
elles viennent chercher c'est là que la
tchéquie elles viennent service avec
l'autriche donc en fait tout le monde le
comprend au bout d'un an au des raisons
idéologiques et dogmatique
on est piégé l'éminence et l' expertise
évidemment du du professeur froguel la
fermeture des frontières justement
précoce ça aurait empêché une certaine
circulation du virus sont c'était un
combat perdu d'avancé pour vous et des
pays qui ont réussi à faire du zéro co
vide en bloquant mieux les frontières
que nous par exemple
ce qui est clair aujourd'hui c'est quand
on arrive à roissy et contrôler son
minimum et à dunkerque la semaine
dernière il y avait plusieurs personnes
qui avaient le col l'aco vide avec un
variant sud africain et qui disaient ils
maintenaient des comores et l'autre
d'afrique du sud justement et qui était
très étonnée d'avoir eu à aucun contrôle
essayer aujourd'hui d'aller en corée du
sud comme des de france parce que j'ai
un fils de mes amis qu'il a fait c'est
pas simplement avec votre test pcr d'il
ya deux jours aux enfers en arrivant
vous met en quarantaine
on est trois fois en ti génique pjc à a
et c est donc ce n'est que trop vrai
ment on est sûr que vous n'êtes pas
porter comme voulait se montrer bien
entendu pas ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en france et c'est ce qui est inquiétant
est que vu la circulation du virus un
peu partout dans le monde
il va y avoir des nouveaux variants qui
vont apparaître peut-être en france mais
peut-être dans un autre pays au brésil
où il ya une très forte circulation
d'autres et si on n'arrive pas à bloquer
ça on va se retrouver avec encore une
floraison de revenus variant froguel de
votre exemple est particulièrement
intéressant parce que vous êtes à la
fois travailleurs en angleterre puisque
vous travaillez à l'impérial collège de
londres et à l'université de lille on
vous laisse passer facilement d'un pays
à l'autre parce que une fois que le
royaume uni se sera débarrassé de son
virus grâce à sa vaccination il s'agira
peut-être pas d'aller leur voile alors
ré apporté depuis la france alors que
nous on sera un petit peu en retard
c'est une vraie question ça moi je
crains que l'on soit parmi les derniers
la france a vacciné très largement notre
population qui va y avoir des sortes de
passeports vaccinaux qui vont se met un
peu partout ce qui va rendre la
population française suspecte et on va
avoir des difficultés à mon avis pendant
l'été à ce mot aller en vacances
ailleurs ou de travailler parce que on
sera très très suspect et d'autres
mettront en place des contrôles des
frontières que nous on n'a pas été
capable de faire et qu'apparemment on a
des preuves de logistique un petit peu
partout aujourd'hui en france et c'est
ça que je n'arrive pas là où j'ai
vraiment un désaccord à ce qu'elle dit
avec moi c'est que j'ai des amis qui ont
participé à la négociation des vaccins
pendant l'été pour gouvernement français
et je veux un peu l'impression qu'une
dès que des erreurs qui avait été fait
était plus de notre niveau
ensuite au niveau européen mais ensuite
la bureaucratie européenne a repris la
main et aggraver tout ça mais il ya eu
des fautes 13 applique pas entendre la
faute principale était de ne pas faire
confiance à pfizer et aux vaccins modern
art puisque on pensait que cette île et
qui marchera jamais il est serait
dangereux qu'il fallait mieux attendre
d'autres vaccins comme le sanofi et oui
comme vous le savez n'arrivera jamais il
ya eu çà au sein de l'union européenne
jean la cape la capelle la france qui a
voulu miser sur son vaccin
malheureusement qui s'est avérée
voilà très fructueux juste avant de vous
répondre bien sûr je réponds aux
professeurs qui a dévié d'une grande
honnêteté intellectuelle parce qu'en
effet j'ai été vous savez ces derniers
mois en russie au kazakhstan au liban
les la réunion dans différents endroits
je suis revenu en france je n'ai jamais
été contrôlé et je suis député européen
comme vous le disiez donc je fais deux
allers-retours par semaine entre
bruxelles et paris je viens de rentrer
de bruxelles dans un train qui
provenaient de d'amsterdam
je n'ai pas été contrée le gars du nord
donc ça n'est pas acceptable très
sincèrement ça n'est pas acceptable
aujourd'hui que dans tous les pays du
monde y ait des frontières qu'ils soient
rigoureuses stricte et qu'en france il
n'y en ait pas et quand vous êtes
contrôlés
si vous n'avez pas votre test on vous
met une amende de 50 euros vous ne
refuse même pas l'intégration sur le
territoire on vous met une amende de 130
euros
ça n'est pas sérieux ça n'est pas
raisonnable ensuite pour revenir à votre
question
bien sûr on a failli mais je vais vous
reprendre l'exemple de valve neva vous
savez cette magnifique start-up cette
magnifique petite boîte dans l'ouest de
la france qui produit des vaccins et
bien dont on n'a pas su profiter et
c'est les britanniques qui ont
finalement acheté l'ensemble du stock
parce qu'ils étaient les premiers tout
simplement à négocier et j'ai beaucoup
d'autres zones comme cela donc c'est
quand on est la deuxième puissance
mondiale et quand on n'a pas un site de
production quand on n'a pas un propres
vaccins avec l'institut pasteur avec
sanofi dont on nous faisait état
promesses on me dira vous inquiétez pas
nous aurons notre vaccin on s'aperçoit
que on a abandonné la recherche on a
totalement désinvesti dans ce domaine là
la délocalisation de la tuer aussi
pendant des années et sanofi en est
aussi responsable très sincèrement comme
le gouvernement français mais nous
sommes mauvais c'est malheureusement le
cas de le dire alors je souhaite que on
se rattrape pas ce que je souhaite pour
protéger notre peuple
je souhaite que tout le monde puisse se
vacciner tous ceux qui le souhaitent
puissent être le plus rapidement
possible écoutez moi mais pas en 85 ans
il habite paris je n'arrive pas à les
faire vacciner
ils ont 85 ans on téléphone y a rien à
faire tout est pris tout est pris on
leur propose et argenteuil d'aller à
argenteuil pour fin mars avec une
deuxième dose 75 jours après hors limite
je ne comprends même pas le système je
ne comprends même pas les règles sur le
temps et pourtant
pardonnez moi je
mais d'ici l'été un sas et jean castex
qu'il dit nous aurons suffisamment de
doses pour avoir proposer la vaccination
à 30 millions de personnes soit les deux
tiers de la population de plus de 18 ans
donc c'est quand même ambitieux le mot
de la fin pour le professeur froguel
vous y croyez à ça je vous dirai juste
ma conclusion ce sera parole parole nous
verrons c'est la fin de la foire qu'on
compte les bouses vadam philippe froguel
le mot de la fin vous y croyez à ses
pronostics optimistes cette promesse du
premier ministre pour que on arrive à
faire ça il faudrait que tu vraiment une
vraie stratégie vaccinale qui n'a pas et
notamment à préparer le monde d'après
c'est là où elle n'est pas par exemple
est intéressant ce que les anglais
veulent utiliser pour une nouvelle
génération de vaccins adaptés à tous les
variants qu'hypo real pourraient
apparaître
la deuxième c'est on est une
méthodologie et la logistique
et tant qu'on n'aura pas de la
logistique je ne vois pas comment on
arrive devra administrer 30 millions de
vaccins alors que on n'arrive pas à en
enregistrer quelques centaines de
milliers j'attends de voir une
logistique qui fonctionne en france et
là effectivement je commencerai à y
croire à la seconde le passé et nous dit
quand même que le futur et pas
obligatoirement aussi radieux que
monsieur kassai technologies merci en
tout cas on terminera sur ses paroles
philippe froguel jenlain la capelle
merci d'avoir été avec nous